[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome happy
thursday it is
day eight
the select hearings
you're gonna be broadcasting live
tonight and no that was not a that was
not a po poc tease i apologize
it's already signed for a long day i
guess i guess it's a sign for a long day
but here we are here we are on thursday
today is the eighth day
that we will hear from the january 6
select committee in public and there's
going to be a few witnesses tonight
we're going to hear from a national
security council advisor who quit after
he watched what trump did or didn't do
or what he did or didn't say uh also the
the deputy press secretary to kaylee
mcinney and the white house also be
testifying uh to probably say how
completely unhinged trump was
at that moment and how he just yeah he
was gonna let the the mob kill his vice
president of the united states i think
that's actually what we're gonna hear
i i mean i i don't know what else we
could
get to the bottom i'm sure we'll have
some details that we may have not heard
before but i think the evidence is going
to be dark
and it's not going to be a fun
experience
and to hear
what donald trump tried to do to our
democracy now
it's going to be exciting in the fact
that there's going to be fireworks here
because the court of public opinion is
about to indict donald trump
for the crimes that he committed on
january 6. now rather merrick garland
does in the department of justice
department of justice does or not
that will be a question for the future
merrick garland made clear yesterday
to the press that no one not one person
is above the law which i think sends a
very a very very big shot over the bow
to donald trump he's
absolutely unhinged over on his
fraudulent social media platform true
social
he can't stop tweeting he can't stop
committing election crime where he's
calling state officials trying to still
get them to overturn
the election of 2020.
he's also stoking fear and stoking
violence
from his post over on true social
uh he's trying to get these people to
save him again is what he's trying to do
i think he would i think he would
actually cheer and clap
and he wouldn't even throw his catch up
against the wall if there was another
another mob that went to
the hearing room and tried to stop the
hearing i think he would love that
he would encourage it and he would be he
would be
tweeting or posting whatever he does
over there on two central as he calls it
the problem that donald trump has is he
doesn't have the megaphone
that he had on january six he does not
have it
people aren't listening he's irrelevant
they want to
cast him
as a pariah in society republicans are
ready to drop this son of a [ __ ] seeing
what's happened in the race in
pennsylvania alone and georgia is enough
to say this guy's [ __ ] done
he picks two [ __ ] candidates that are
getting their asses kicked already
i mean people are making their decision
right now in pennsylvania
of who they're going to vote for in the
senate race and it's probably not going
to change
we'll probably show the uh the wizard of
oz video that we have
midas touch put out yesterday it was
actually on morning joe i think this
morning
a great video we'll probably play that
today
but that race is crucial
but donald trump wanted this political
fight the republicans wanted this
political fight mitch mcconnell knew
that donald trump would not survive the
politics of a january 6 select committee
and all of these republicans coming and
testifying against him these are not
democrats he's not [ __ ] liberals get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
these are trump loyalists these are
people who wanted to work with this
[ __ ]
that came to testify against him jesus
christ they
they censored rusty bowers the house
speaker in arizona because he came and
told the truth
he's pressuring with the wisconsin
assembly speaker to try to overturn the
election there because the supreme court
made a stupid [ __ ] decision
to not have secure ballot drop boxes
which is really [ __ ] dumb
really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
that this is this is the the election
work that lawyers and courts are doing
to make sure not to have secure ballot
boxes for people to drop their ballots
in
to make sure that they drop them in
unsecured ballot boxes called mailboxes
really [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
but it's not surprising with trumpism
it's not surprising and tonight you're
probably not going to be surprised
i really don't think there's going to be
anything tonight that will surprise me
it will shock you
it's going to be dark
of what this [ __ ] idiot tried to do
to our democracy and really it's the his
mindset
it's his mindset of the democracy
that is going to be very dark he doesn't
realize that he
held an office our office our office of
the president of the united states he
does not realize that he still to this
day
doesn't realize that he thought he was a
king he really thinks the president is a
king
even even four years of experience the
office himself he still did not
understand it
and we see with the secret service which
i think we're gonna have gabe sanchez
explain to us today how hard it is to
delete
to hard delete a [ __ ] text message
like you can delete it off your phone
right but like to get rid of the
existence of the text message forever
i want to go through that and see
exactly what gabe thinks as far as
deleting you know gabe is our executive
producer co-host but he's our tech
expert as well
he knows a lot more about technology
and the ins and outs and details than i
do
so we're going to see what he thinks
about how hard it is for the secret
service and i think
that's another criminal case that is
going to
going to play out in public
that it's not gonna be good for donald
trump this is just none of it is good
for him
but tonight is gonna be a very dark a
dark day in american history
where
members of congress have to lay out that
the former president united states tried
to overthrow our government commit a
coup
and he wanted
his mob that he
sicked on the capitol and laid siege to
the capitol he wanted them to kill his
vice president
if if that vice president wouldn't do
what he wanted
and he's still doing it like he's still
doing this stuff he hasn't stopped
and that may be another reason why doj
hasn't acted quite yet he's still crying
like as we [ __ ] speak he's criming
right now he's probably tampering with
witnesses as i speak
into this microphone
texting calling
telling someone else to call telling
someone else to tell them
be a friend
you'll be a friend if you do this favor
[ __ ] like that
jesus christ we watched a video
yesterday
of the wisconsin assembly speaker saying
he talked to donald trump last week and
donald trump
wouldn't take no for an answer
is what the video basically says
i told him several times that is not how
it works
and he had a different opinion is the
way that he put it
he tried to pressure me into overturn
doing something illegal is what the
assembly speaker was saying
he wants
his supporters
his violent
fascist
ninja poop nazi supporters
to go commit violence
and to save him here
he knows he's in big trouble not just
criminally
this this
court of public opinion
is going to crush him he will never he
will never be able to beat a primary a
good primary contender now when i mean
good i mean good as far as fascist he'll
never be be able to beat another decent
fascist oh yeah god damn you just gonna
be a fascist well you can beat donald
trump veron desantis will [ __ ] run
laps
around donald trump in a fascist primary
these fascist voters will vote for
desantis all day every day
over trump
who has proven not only to be irrelevant
but now going to be a pariah in society
he's unpatriotic he's un-american he's a
criminal he's a traitor
and we're gonna find that out tonight
and we already knew this right like this
is did some of these things in the
select hearings we already knew
we knew of these things
the media has reported on them
journalists have done a really good job
of getting some of this stuff out into
the into the public
but we never had the hard facts right it
was always a source said or this was
here or they're working on this source
to say
but now it's being laid out in front of
you
and laid out in front of america
and as we go through the tick tock of
the 187 minutes tonight
you might want to take notes
and the reason why is because tomorrow
morning
because this is in prime time folks
tomorrow morning
the country is gonna know
what donald trump did do or more
importantly what he did not do
to stop the mob from killing his vice
president
our government and trying to tear it to
the ground i think the other thing that
we're going to find out tonight too
about mike pence by the way which
that's a whole nother [ __ ] ball of
wax rather mike pence is a hero or mike
pence sitting a hero and blah blah blah
and we can go through the mike pence
thing if you want to hear my opinion on
that
i'll give it trust me
but i think the other thing we're going
to find out tonight is what what is the
reason why mike pence held up in that
parking garage
during that 187 minutes
why was he there
and what did he know the president was
doing what did he know he wasn't doing i
think that's part of the tick tock that
we're gonna get tonight
now we know mark short his chief of
staff
has given video deposition we haven't
seen a lot from mark short's deposition
but we know he spent hours being deposed
by the january 6th select committee and
their attorneys
and i'm sure tonight we will find out
what the inner workings were
of that that hold up in the parking
garage and what was happening
the exact moments that they knew that
trump was not acting
to save the government
to try to hold it together
and i think mark short was standing
right there by the vice president
knowing those things so we'll see if
they get to the bottom of that in the
deposition
but speaking of mike pence
speaking of mike pence he is no [ __ ]
hero here
and i know i know the committee wants to
make him into a hero to get him to come
sit in front of the committee either to
be deposed or in public
and i i think mike pence
may be able to repair his reputation
here if he did such a thing he's not
going to
mike pence is not going to come and be
deposed or sit in front of the committee
it's probably not going to happen but
that's why they're trying to make him
into the hero
they don't want to send the signal that
the select committee is his enemy
that they're after him
mike pence thinks he's gonna be
president someday which he will not be
not even close
but when we do find out tonight exactly
the what mike pence was thinking and
exactly what donald trump was doing to
make sure
that mike pence either did what he
wanted what trump wanted him to do or he
was going to make sure his mob killed
him
and he was excited about this watching
tv apparently we already have clips adam
kensinger has released a few clips he
was excited he was watching tv he loved
it it was like he was watching a [ __ ]
football game
but as we find out what this chucklehead
was doing i actually believe this is
going to peel support
away from donald trump and the reason
why is because
in 2016 there was a lot of people i know
personally who voted for trump and i
asked him why in the [ __ ] would you vote
for that piece of [ __ ]
and there was a theme amongst them
because they were like oh well mike
pence is a good christian so he'll make
sure mike pence i didn't really vote for
trump i voted for pen they'll impeach
him so quickly he'll quit he won't
survive mike pence will be the president
blah blah blah blah blah
on and on and on it went which mike
pence is a [ __ ] bigot
he's not a [ __ ] christian a christian
generally follows i don't know the new
testament and the bible
nothing nothing in that side of the
[ __ ] book describes any of these
[ __ ] christian nationalists not a
[ __ ] thing not a goddamn thing and
it's such a false equivalency to even
call these [ __ ] christian
nationalists
they're [ __ ] nazis is what they are
one
you want to do
[ __ ] therapy on on on gay people and
you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] don't don't
want people to marry the people they
love
you don't want women to have procedures
that will save their goddamn lives
medical procedures that are
safe to save their life get the [ __ ] out
of here that none of that is christian
not a goddamn bit of it you want to
marry children in tennessee
come on get the [ __ ] out of here you're
christian no you're not christian
but that's the reason why they voted for
trump is he selected a good christian
and what they meant was is ah you know
he they he he had he selected
a saltine cracker that poses as a
christian as his vice president
but what they're gonna wake up to
tomorrow these same people these same
[ __ ] that voted for trump
because pence is a great christian or
some [ __ ]
these same [ __ ] are gonna wake
up
tomorrow morning
realizing that trump
didn't give a [ __ ] if they killed him
especially if he didn't do what he
wanted him to do which is make him
[ __ ] king
this wasn't about the next four years
it wasn't about being president for
another four more years
it was about undermining our democracy
so he could remain leader forever
that's what it was about
and hopefully the select committee gets
to the bottom of that tonight now
speaking of presidents and vice
presidents i don't want to ignore the
news
now president biden has tested positive
for covet apparently he has mild
symptoms he's got a runny nose and a
cough i guess
they're taking um
precautions obviously they have a
protocol there at the white house uh for
the president to have coveted there's an
actual plan in place huh
who who'd have thunk that that that you
should put a plan in place and some in
case something like this would happen
of course the internet's going crazy
about uh
vice president kamala harris
she might be the president or some [ __ ]
well i mean look if the president united
states the office holder the person that
holds the office our office it's ours
god damn it
that's our [ __ ] office that's our
executive
ours us the people
if the person the the person who holds
that office dies
then we have protocol that's that's
called policy and government
and the vice president becomes the
president
that's that's why we have a vice
president i mean other than to preside
over the senate
this really [ __ ] again this is
bone-headed type [ __ ] that we can't
figure this out that's like then when
they want to [ __ ]
impeach biting well they'll have
president harris
god forbid the worst happened in a
president pass away
the vice president will become the
president
we've actually seen this happen before
like in modern history even
where the vice president becomes the
president either because the president
dies and and is deceased
or the president resigns and leaves
office
we've seen this
it's not difficult to understand the
procedure
so the internet freakout is really
[ __ ] bone-headed and dumb because
biden has a call from covid he's got the
vaccine
he's been boosted they're taking
precautions they're giving him they're
they're medicating him in a certain way
and i'm sure because he's the president
of the united states
he has access to some of the greatest
medicine in the world which
all citizens should have that access
but in this country with capitalism and
everything else and
these [ __ ] greedy bastards have to
make so much money off prescription
drugs and health care they don't
understand health care should be a
[ __ ] absolute right and everyone
should have the ability to receive
treatment and the best treatment that
that we can provide for them
and that's now i'll digress on that
but i'm i listen
trump they didn't have a plan for trump
when he got governed you remember this
there was no [ __ ] plan there wasn't a
plan they didn't even have a plan in
place for the president to get covered
when trump that's how [ __ ] worthless
they were
everyone's standing around wondering
2020 why our [ __ ] country was so
jacked up
they didn't even have a plan for the
president of the united states in 2020
when donald trump was in charge of [ __ ]
when if when and if he got covered no
[ __ ] plan they waited until that
[ __ ] was damn near collapsed to
put him on a goddamn helicopter to life
flight him to walter reed
you remember this
there was no [ __ ] plan and then they
got him walter reed and there was still
no [ __ ] plan they didn't have a
[ __ ] plan no protocol they ain't need
no who needs a [ __ ] plan
i mean that's how you run governments
you just throw [ __ ] at the wall and see
if it sticks with a bunch of dumbasses
but here you have
president biden gets a normal protocol
he has a runny nose he has a cough the
physician
they test him for coed he tests positive
they follow the protocol the [ __ ]
physician releases the statement they're
not trying to hide it they're not trying
to [ __ ] oh no it wasn't this wasn't
that he's not feeling bad oh no lying
all over the [ __ ] place
that's the difference
that's the difference aaron's like oh
democrats and republicans are the same
[ __ ] they are not the same thing
they are not the same thing stop that
nonsense
that is such [ __ ] democrats in this
country the party as a whole are the
only [ __ ] that are interested
in democracy the only ones
there's not too many goddamn republicans
that are interested in the truth or
democracy and the ones that are are in
are pariahs in their party jesus christ
they just censored rusty bowers because
he came and told the truth the arizona
party he's the speaker
he's one of their
major party leaders in arizona and
they're like [ __ ] you you told the truth
you can't do that that's that's too much
for democracy you son of a [ __ ]
censor them now
you see the two start differences in
between the last president getting coven
testing positive for coven and this
president you already see the [ __ ]
differences
it is not complicated to understand
why it's so [ __ ] boneheaded for
anyone who's pro-democracy out there to
claim that both parties are the same and
when someone says that [ __ ] when someone
tells you
says to your face or in some [ __ ]
thread or some stupid [ __ ] or says it on
tv or some kind of internet tv station
or wherever the [ __ ] youtube channel
they say democrats and republicans are
the exact same thing they're [ __ ]
lying to you
they're lying to you and they're not for
democracy they're not and i will
challenge them come here
and prove to me that you are
if you think they're the same
every little bit piece of news proves it
every single [ __ ] bit of it i mean
yesterday we watched a [ __ ] clip a
pete buda judge absolutely wad up scott
perry and throw him in the [ __ ] trash
about electric vehicles and gasoline and
energy
and it's not like it was some kind of
deep conversation p buddha just like
well i knew you were going to talk about
this because you're a [ __ ] liar so i
brought
i brought some some statistics i brought
some prices
and i'm gonna show you that you're a
[ __ ] idiot
the two parties are not the same
they're not there's a fascist party
there's an insurgency party that we have
in this country that wants to tear down
our democracy
that wants to make us a fascist state
the motto is in florida
donald trump only wishes he was half as
good of a fascist as ron desantis
but here we are
and tonight
for this hearing we're going to find out
exactly
exactly how they plan to steal our
democracy how exactly they planned to
turn this into an autocracy and make
donald trump the king we're gonna find
that out and we're gonna know exactly
what that son of a [ __ ] the crimes that
he committed
we're gonna see it to bear and the court
of public opinion will indict him so i
urge you
go to the midas touch network youtube
channel
make sure to click day eight the link
for day eight the hearing for day eight
we will broadcast an hour before
so seven eastern is when our coverage
will start
the gavel goes down at eight eastern but
we will have commentary from the great
midas touch network panel the likes of
uh a midas mighty favorite texas paul
we'll have the mizellas brothers from
the midas touch podcast we'll have the
legal af staff michael popock which i
kind of had a snafu with the po poc pop
in earlier but popock will join us
tonight he will be joining us karen
ignifiglow kfa from legal af will be
joining us
jessica denson the trump nba killer
david bender the political strategist
will be joining us tonight
before during the break and then after
we will have many commentators hopefully
we'll have a few big surprises there at
the very end after the hearing
to break down what just happened so
stick around after the hearing tonight
as well we will have a great midas touch
network panel after the hearings so
don't forget
seven eastern
seven eastern sixth central
4 pacific is when our coverage starts go
to the minus touch
network youtube channel
and set your reminder tonight is going
to be a banger folks
it's gonna be a banger
and boy are we gonna find out
exactly
what the cheeto dust mobster was up to
in overthrowing our government and
trying
to have his mob kill
his vice president of the united states
stick around we will be right back right
after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product
and blanket i've got you covered part in
blanket specifically works to make you
feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on january 6th and if you're
one of the other members of congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
pardon blanket will protect you too
pardon blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're a hundred percent made in the
usa don't delay and get your pardon
blanket today for just 99.99
actual partying is not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
we are at the bottom of the hour of the
tony michaels podcast we air every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
again go to the minus touch youtube
channel
make sure to set your reminder for the
hearing tonight we will begin at 7
eastern with our coverage with the midas
touch network
panel
do not miss it tonight is going to be
the big one
tonight is the finale of this season
of the january 6 select hearings
and we we we've had eight of them after
tonight there will be eight hearings
and they really went through a tick tock
here of how many times that they tried
to really overthrow our democracy
and this is the eighth
eighth way that they tried to overthrow
our democracy and donald trump
the evidence will bear that he
personally him
that [ __ ] idiot
thought that he could get away with
taking away our vote
and stealing our election away from us
he really thought he could get away with
it they tried many different ways
oh there was a lot of different ways
they tried the state legislators they
tried the electors they tried the court
system they tried the supreme court they
tried to over they tried to get the
department of justice to declare that he
was king of the castle
he incited a mob
he knew they had weapons he knew they
wanted to be violent and he sent them to
the capitol to kill mike pence and other
politicians
so that they'd certify the vote for him
whatever that means i still wondering
you know chuck grassley
would have presided over the senate if
mike pence would not have presided or
could not have presided
grassley kind of sent the signal almost
like some you know someone had called
him
and let him know hey don't let mike
pence preside you should preside and
crown me king i don't know maybe someone
called him maybe someone didn't
i don't know
i don't know we got a lot of news to get
to today i have some video i want to get
to
so let's go to
the shitless roundup you know we round
up all the tweety tweets and trendy
trends all the new listeners out there
this is this is one of the the audience
favorites where we go through twitter
and we round up all the actual video we
do reactions right here on the air live
my co-host gabe sanchez normally joins
me i think he's a little late this
morning
it must have been a rough night tonight
it's going to be a big day so he must be
he must be doing his hair or you know
getting ready for today because today's
a big day folks
but we round up all the tweety tweets
and trendy trends now for you to know
what's going on what is trending what to
watch for what to look for and we give
you commentary live right on the air so
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have reached the point of the show
where we've round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends in the [ __ ]
list roundup
everyone's
making um guesses of why gabe isn't here
i'm not sure he's probably listening
and
margie says
he's he's fixing his soda stream
oh boy i really i i love the audience
here now when you pick on gabe just a
little bit about a soda stream did you
guys see the video that he released
yesterday we played it yesterday on the
podcast about alex stein
[Music]
and
there was a lot of comments on that
video
but but patriot takes um found this
morning and i want to i want to go to
this here
uh maybe gabe will join us in the in the
in the interim as i go to this let me
let me send let me ping him up and see
if he's uh see if he's ready here
maybe he'll be there
oh he okay he's i think he's i think
he's working because he's got a he's got
a he's got another what was that that
he's trying to work on yeah you see he's
messing me he listened to me now he
knows i'm done he knows we're he knows
we're talking about him
but he's got another what was that that
he's trying to work on and i believe
he's breaking down
uh the hearing
uh number seven so the last one for an
update tonight
so i think that's what he's working on
currently but let's go to
here's a tweet the patriot takes sent
out
now you know the the what was that
yesterday
uh he did about this this alex stein you
guys know this alex 9 99 this [ __ ]
idiot
this this tucker carlson wannabe
trying to trying to sexually harass
women on the capitol steps congress
women
in particular aoc
to be exact
going and sexually harassing them when a
[ __ ] idiot
but it's not a surprise
it's not a surprise that he would have
nick fuentes on his show
now the man who sexually harassed aoc
just had a white nationalist nick
fuentes on his podcast he also announced
that he's working with turning points
usa
and will be at their student
action summit
i don't know that i'd let this person
around students
the way that he sexually harasses
congress people and he lets nick fuentes
this [ __ ] nazi
nick fuentes is a nazi
and here he's excited to have him on
what in the [ __ ]
so if you're wondering who alex how um
alex
stein is
alex stein is a goddamn white
nationalist
that's what alex stein
is and he's a [ __ ] racist and he's a
[ __ ] nazi
as far as i'm concerned and i don't know
if you watched the what was that
yesterday about alex stein
but this son of a [ __ ] has had a
history
of physically
assaulting women because he did it
inside and during a reality tv show
you can see the footage on the what was
that just
go over to our youtube channel you can
subscribe
to our youtube channel that playlist of
what was that is down in the playlist
go check out the one from yesterday on
alex stein
and know who that son of a [ __ ] is that
was
sexually harassing
aoc on the steps and why he was saying
the [ __ ] he was saying about her the
reason why is because he's he's in the
likes of nick fuentes
[ __ ] white nationalist all right
let's go back to the uh the thread here
dude
oh here is uh brett my zealous uh posted
very cool this is the uh
the wizard of lies
uh the the video that midas touch did
about dr oz
was on
morning joe this morning midas aaron has
it here
uh here let's watch the let's watch the
coverage here
the wizard of lies
take a look
[Music]
we'd like you to keep your promise to us
if you please sir
and now i've got the number one miracle
in a bottle
so it was featured this morning on msnbc
on on morning joe thank you aaron for
for sharing that
and letting us know that midas touch
made the news so the midas touch super
pac made the news again with their ad
against dr oz and you guys know that the
fetterman
is running a hell of a campaign out
there in pennsylvania
and really it's
it shouldn't be hard but this veteran
brand of d of democrats
is is the brand that all democrats need
to adopt here
taking the gloves off and beating the
holy piss out of these fascists
politically you know we need to beat him
up politically and there's no one that
does this better too than this brand of
coming right after the son of a [ __ ]
and pete buddha judge we played yes
yesterday a video of him and
in a congressional meeting where he's
being questioned by the trader scott
perry about the price of electric
vehicles and of course of course that
trader scott perry was [ __ ] lying of
course he was
well let's watch p buda judge here on tv
just absolutely
throw these idiots in the trash pete
pete buddha judge is one of the best at
this
the realities may set in in europe but
we may see the downside of for example
if the president declares a a climate
emergency executive order we are going
to stop oil and gas drilling in the
outer continental shelf we're going to
do all kinds of things that it will
limit production
of hydrocarbons at this time with the
idea that by 2030 everyone else is going
to be along with us and that it will
somehow you think we're going to
we're going to be able to change the
weather between or the climate between
now and 2030.
i want to point out something real quick
here it's hotter than a [ __ ] it
is hotter than a son of a [ __ ]
all around this country all around this
world it is hotter than a [ __ ]
and these bastards know it they know
what's happening they know it's the
climate is changing they know why
they know they [ __ ] know it's that
it's the whole hoax thing because it
digs into big money's pockets
and they don't like when it when when
the truth digs into big money's pockets
so they'd much rather just [ __ ] lie
about it
but this goes back and pete buddha judge
does a fantastic job here what i was
talking about the other day is
liberalism is not weak
liberalism is actually
it's what makes
our democracy [ __ ] tough
makes it tough rigid
it makes it to be able to fight because
these people want to lay down in front
of fascism and profits
and and and a few people in this country
who run [ __ ] they want to lay down in
front of them and just let them run
rough shot over us [ __ ] that
that is why the
these [ __ ] dumbasses around the
country who thinks liberals are are weak
are
absolutely delusional liberalism is the
toughest part of democracy that's the
toughest part
do you know how difficult it is to get a
consensus of everyone to agree on
exactly what liberty they want to have
and how they want to achieve it it is
super [ __ ] difficult it is tough
it is a [ __ ] fight it's easy to pick
a dictator and let them tell you what
the [ __ ] to do
but here we have poop pee poo to judge
absolutely showing this dumb
[ __ ] i don't even know who this
stupid bastard's name is
on cnbc
squawk box or whatever the hell it's
called here
but pete put a judge does an excellent
job at showing and telling the son of a
[ __ ] that liberalism
actual liberal democracy a small l don't
freak out conservatives
is the tough
that's the toughness that comes from
western democracy
that's the john wayne toilet paper type
[ __ ] rough tough and doesn't take [ __ ]
off nobody that's liberalism
let's listen
with what challenges we've changed the
climate between 20 we've changed the
climate between 2010 and now and not in
a good way so yes we can and must act to
make sure that we reverse the worst
effects of climate change look some of
it's upon us right now there this is not
a question about whether it's going to
happen or whether it's not going to keep
right it's a question
they're going to keep rising it's a
question of how many lives and how many
livelihoods are going to be destroyed by
allowing the worst effects of climate
change to happen right now people you
know i've never known the united states
i've never known the united states for
something that may or may not happen by
2030.
they're dying from the heat because of a
climate-related extreme weather we're
not going to cover sooner or later
in the meantime they need
energy to cool their homes and to heat
their homes in the meantime right and as
you as you know i mean the other thing
that's striking is i've noticed some
naysayers in in the us speaking as if
the only power sources that are exist
that exist are solar wind and
hydrocarbon obviously in europe they
have a mix that
relies partly on nuclear we have more
options that are being developed in the
us as well as being smarter and more
efficient with the energy that we have
energy efficiency has often been
described as the fifth fuel
and in the transportation side of things
finding less carbon intensive ways to to
move our vehicles obviously the leading
and most visible example of that's
electric vehicles that's why we're
fighting to make evs cheaper and it's
why we're getting these charging
stations out across the country but i've
just i've never known the united states
to be a country that looks around the
world and says what's the lowest common
denominator let's do that or we don't
have control over every piece of it so
let's sit back
accept the status quo and let some other
country lead that's not what america
does and i think what you're going to
see from the president today is an
assist insistence that america should be
leading the way and challenging the rest
of the world to catch up to us instead
of matching uh some other country that
isn't doing a very good job hmm it seems
like pete buddha just agrees with me
what do you think gabe sanchez gave here
to join us what do you think i think i
think gabe i gabe i think pete buddha
judge understands that liberalism is the
[ __ ] toughness of democracy it is the
toughness of the western world it is the
toughness that brought us to where we
are at today not this capitulating to
whomever we want to capitulate like he
said the lowest common denominator which
is what trumpism wants what fascism
wants it always wants it just wants
profits it doesn't care everyone's
profits and power they don't give a [ __ ]
about the people i mean uh president
biden's actions yesterday they didn't
add he didn't actually go as far
for uh calling an emergency of climate
stopped short of that
but i mean really
we're going to see in the next 20 years
and these it's gonna piss off these
[ __ ] conservatives but people are
gonna need money for climate like right
we're gonna have to really dig in and
spend money if we don't if we don't
start doing it now well i mean it's the
same thing as infrastructure right this
is part of infrastructure which is which
is building in anticipation for the
future to say like if i don't do it now
to prepare ourselves to avoid some sort
of calamity
or just utter destruction of the
of the foundation beneath us which is
you know what you see with uh you know
highways and roads like telecom broad
broadband these are all things that we
need as a society to keep advancing and
keep going if those things kind of
crumble beneath us
then then what happens to us as a
society right we fail and this is
another thing which is energy we will
not
we will not go down in energy
consumption right as the population
increases the energy consumption also
increases that is a direct relationship
so what we have to do is prepare
for that world or that that reality that
is coming forward with us especially as
republicans want everyone to have babies
right unwilling
to allow people to choose
so if you've enforced
and it's just one of those things where
it's like if they're unwilling or rather
yeah if they're if they're if they're
forcing people to have babies and
they're forcing the population to
increase and they're unwilling to do the
things necessary to make sure that we
are energy independent right as pete
said it's not just wind solar and hydro
car right like it's not just those
things but we need to put
the systems in place
to protect ourselves for the future i
mean you look at texas right they run
off a privatized grid and that [ __ ] has
failed non-stop especially in the last
two years
right so you you look at this and you're
like
it
it's it's a no-brainer right but
republicans are like uh how how bad can
i [ __ ] the people over
that are supposed to be my boss my
constituents as yes scott perry said yes
creator like what the [ __ ] is that you
know
like if they really were if if they can
if you really believe that
that their constituents were their boss
right they had to answer to them
then they would do
their job right however their boss
their their actual constituents might be
people like lobbyists the people that
are putting money in their pockets that
say hey that's their don't say this or
don't say that on a bill or vote this
way or vote that way right so
i mean if we if we play if we play this
game you know the next 20 30 years where
we capitulate to the people who are who
are getting us into a downward spiral a
spiral instead of giving the power to
the people and saying hey
we need to really take back our
democracy we need to have good policy
set in place to move forward and again
the guy the guy on the screen is like oh
my god what are we gonna do in the next
five years what are we gonna do in the
meantime this is this same [ __ ] freak
out game that that ensued on us for the
last six months about gas prices is if
the world was gonna end because because
the supply was was diminished because of
the war in ukraine and and there's
several other factors but the price of
gasoline went up at the pump and the
president didn't he didn't freak out the
world didn't freak out they're just
acting to try to make sure the supply is
up so that so that people aren't [ __ ]
going broke at the pump it's almost like
the price went down right and it's
almost like they have a plan right right
well i even said this this morning about
the covet thing he's got coven and
everyone's like oh my god he's got co
and i'm like look the reason why you
even know that the president is covet is
because they're [ __ ] outright honest
they're doing what they should be doing
if this was [ __ ] trump or any other
republican we they would still be lying
this morning about the status of a
republican and actually what he really
would be doing is he'd be showing up to
events like right coughing on people and
then getting them sick right you have a
super spreader for scotus you've got him
going to a debate and people knew that
right covered and then he was spreading
that you know thankfully
not as many people got covered from his
interactions but like yeah if it was
trump you wouldn't know [ __ ] until
somebody eats something where it was
like oh he's having a hard time
breathing well [ __ ] they they didn't
even do any they didn't even do anything
about it until the son of a [ __ ] need
to be life flighted to walter don't read
for crying out loud
they're like oh it's totally fine
no if it was totally fine he would just
be you know he wouldn't have to be
airlifted or you know it wouldn't have
to be taken off in a helicopter to go to
walter reed hospital right like it's it
is it is insane
this is the difference this is the
difference though we talk about that
we've been talking about this over and
over because this is the [ __ ] we're
getting in the midterm is democrats are
the same as they are not the same
now now i mean
do democrats in the party and the party
itself have problems of course they do
but but the one the number one issue
here
is that the only way for us to fix any
of these things like pete buddha judge
is talking about like people want to
codify roe v wade which i think we
should codify roe v wade i think we
should codify uh a
same-sex marriage i think there's a lot
of things that we could do i think we
can make sure to codify voting rights
there's a lot of things that we can do
but we can't do it if we don't form a
government that is willing to do it and
trust me if you just give up and let the
republicans win that government that you
form by not voting because by you not
voting are you not participating and you
not engaging in democracy
you are choosing that government
it's us the people the choices we make
make our government make our democracy
so if you choose not to participate not
to engage and the republicans take over
you chose that yeah and they're not
going to codify [ __ ] they're gonna
they're gonna take your [ __ ] away
they're gonna take your [ __ ] rights
away they're gonna take your [ __ ]
money away you don't take your [ __ ]
power away your ac away they don't give
a [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] you know
and you know i'll say it again from
yesterday and the day before like just
because you may live in a state or a
region or area that you're like well
it's always blue so my vote doesn't
matter whether i vote or don't vote
right
that type of dismissive kind of
doesn't really matter for me right
doesn't help the overall
group that we are as a country right
just because you feel that you
don't need to vote
when you tell people or when you say
things out loud whether you're tyt or
whoever it is to be like well it doesn't
matter because i live in this area you
know i don't feel like it doesn't you
know i can vote or not vote like again
you are broadcasting this message even
if you're one person in your community
and you say that
it's not just the national election you
know there are local elections that
matter
so the fact that you're saying that
doesn't really matter if i vote or not
no it does matter because when you say
that
that message will resonate throughout
your community whether you're someone on
a podcast like us or you have a show or
you have a voice for millions or you
just again just you're just one vote
just one vote
that matters it matters spread it well
the other thing too is when you're
actually engaging with your family your
friends your your your fellow church
members you know the the the people that
you you you hang out with that you
socialize with if you're like
blah blah blah blah blah democracy yeah
huge cape
no button bernie busta if i don't get
bernie if i don't have this listen the
bust is now
the bust is now the bus that you guys
wanted back in 2016 that's right now
right now is the bus that you're seeing
it wasn't back then
it wasn't that she was gonna lose the
bust is here it's in front of you now do
something about it
now do something about it so engage get
into your into the mindset of
pro-democracy and find those candidates
find find where you can help anyways
those small candidates those local
elections
they are you know for lack of a better
term everyone is grooming a candidate to
be up to a higher level whether you're
on the the board at a school
right or you're on uh
an hoa or or you're moving yourself up
to a council member or a representative
or a senator or a governor or you know
the president like whatever it is like
you know people are trying to attain a
higher level of success and power
and it doesn't just say okay well you
know what i'm
i'm council member that's enough for me
maybe there are all those people but for
the most for the majority like you know
either party is going to be building
those people up to higher positions so
if you're letting some [ __ ] crazy q
anon conspiracy theorist that doesn't
believe
in in science
or says that oh it's god's will that
children are slaughtered by an ar-15
like these are the people that are if
you don't vote if you don't say anything
these are the people that are going to
get into office so not voting is not an
option
right and not participating you have to
engage in the battle again we cannot
have what i was saying the other day we
cannot have
this defeatist ultimate defeatist
ultimatum which is well if uh if i don't
get the way that i want right then i
just don't vote right 100 and nothing a
hundred percent of nothing
is nothing right that's what it is a
hundred listen to the words a hundred
percent of nothing is nothing you cannot
have this all or nothing this all or
nothing
you are you are only helping the other
side oh well somebody should primarily
buy i don't give a [ __ ] right now if
that's the situation that you want to
talk about i'm worried about 2022 right
now right that's the most important
election have a very very impactful
effect on what happens for 2024
right like the idea that people are
always saying oh we got to take joe up i
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up right now that
is not what we should be talking about
right by you talking about that you are
only adding fuel to the fire for the
other side to use against us because
what's going to happen is oh look at the
democrats they're infighting they're in
fighting [ __ ] that [ __ ] now right we're
all on the same team we're on the same
team we have one goal the goal is if you
don't i don't care whatever you think
about 2024 right now the goal is to
defeat fascism
right and if you start fighting within
the party and being like well it doesn't
really matter if i vote or you know the
the the democrats are fickle and they're
not gonna give me the ten thousand
dollar student loan i don't care about
that right now okay if we let 2022 go
then 2024 is not even an option you you
aren't you're already gonna be all get a
student loan or go to college under
these fascists they'll choose who goes
to college and who doesn't go to college
speaking of fascist there's some news
this morning gabe uh
former trump strategist steve bannon
that [ __ ] traitor now hugo has it
here new former trump strategist steve
bannon is not putting on the defense in
his contempt of congress trial so he's
just gonna take it well so i'm i mean he
doesn't really i mean i don't know what
defense he would mount here now hugo has
this uh glenn glenn also had something
um this similar let me pull up his tweet
well yesterday i saw part of his press
conference or
press conference after the fact which
was with a whistling guy which was
amazing right which brings back memories
of uh martin killer group
and matt gates getting whistled off from
there we will not back down and then ran
away
so yeah it's uh but in that one he was
like bringing up benny thompson having
covet and the jan6 committee and it was
like right that's his defense because
here's here's what steve bannon realizes
that they're going to lose they're going
to lose in this [ __ ] court case yeah
he's he's lost i mean just like peter
navarro none of these guys remember
these guys were the authors the people
who constructed the green bay sweep the
people who literally went on to the
radio shows and the tv shows and wrote
books about it and said this is how
we're gonna overturn the government
right and they're like well i didn't do
anything illegal yes you did and you
keep talking about it but you won't tell
the the jan six committee and now you
have subpoenas against you uh or you
rather you fail to follow the subpoena
and now you have contempt of congress
charges against you so i think the
prosecutors did something smart here and
and uh glenn could tell us more because
he's a former prosecutor but i think
they did something smart in the navarro
case they actually offered him a plea
deal they turned it down
but i think the conviction of steve
bannon here only solidifies more that
navarro was [ __ ] and oh yeah they did
that on purpose and i think they're not
going to give him back his good deal
that he probably would have gotten i i
would imagine that peter navarro would
have walked away with this
contempt misdemeanor a judge if he would
have gave something um but that's only
one that was only one of the two charges
right off the dog offered him to plea
and then he said
yeah right
right but but here's the thing it's like
i think the judge probably would have
just put an ankle brace around and gave
him a couple months of home confinement
and he would have been on on and about
his way to you know other criminal
trials possibly um and and actually
prove that he was a cooperating witness
and maybe get some maybe get some relief
when he goes to federal prison for a
bigger crime than just contempt of
congress because this is a misdemeanor
but it's up to two years in prison i
think i think bannon knows that now i
know bannon
i know he's got a really
feel that he's going to be convicted
here by this jury
and the thing that i think the reason
why they're not putting on defense but
but let me read glenn's tweet here
lynn kishner says here defense will not
be putting on a case no witnesses no
evidence and steve as much as he loves
to talk and whine and complain and troll
will not be testifying his own events
how very predictable and i think what
glenn is alluding to here and this is my
thought
is that steve bannon doesn't want to go
before the judge they don't want to call
witnesses or evidence because they don't
want that as part of
his sentencing okay so you got to
remember if steve bannon really believes
that he's going to be convicted here he
knows he's going to go before a
magistrate to be sentenced right he
knows the sentence is i think it's up to
a hundred thousand dollars in two years
what he's trying to do is make sure
because he's really [ __ ] pissed this
judge off he's pissed this judge off
several times so he's trying in the
trial to show that hey
i know it's done
convict me and i think that if they
don't [ __ ] try any funny business
during the trial
then i think the magistrate that
sentenced him is gonna go soft on him
that's what steve bannon is hoping for
here right that's what he's hoping for
um because steve bannon and donald trump
specifically do not want him to serve
prison time they want home confinement
they want him to be able to talk into a
microphone
from his home to keep up the [ __ ]
dark web propaganda and keep [ __ ]
diluting these people and brainwashing
these people and dumping just toxic
[ __ ] fascist sewage into the mines of
america right because here's the thing
the next two years matter he's gonna
need it right
you go into the midterms and you go into
the actual election of 2024
he's gonna need a voice like no other
depending on whatever the you know his
decision is if he runs or he doesn't run
but either way
those two years are going to be pivotal
for trump to use bannon as a as a
soapbox absolutely one and and i'm not
sure
maybe check scott mcfarland why i move
on here see if there's any updates
because i i would bet since they're not
going to provide they're not going to
put on a defense that this is probably
going to close pretty quick today um so
they'll probably convene the jury now
because he mounted no defense
it is likely that the jury will come to
a quick decision here um just because
there is i mean i mean he mounted none
no defense whatsoever so he's expecting
to be convicted um
again i just believe he's not causing
any kind of havoc inside the trial so
that way when he is sentenced they go
soft on him right
to put it to put it in so many words but
yeah basically uh
navarro he's he's being left out in the
[ __ ] cold man like he's well he's
like he's gonna he's gonna be holding
the bag of [ __ ] he probably went through
thinking like oh these guys are gonna
fight it so we're gonna keep
in whatever delusion that it is that he
believes he even had a case right you
have to remember that this is the guy
that wrote a book
about what they did
right and so well and not only did he
write a book he goes on arie melbersher
show and other shows yeah all the time
admitting that they were committing
crimes
like just outright saying yeah we yeah
we did that crime yeah we did that crime
but and he's like but that's not a crime
and ari's like
that sounds like a crime
and he's like no no no just because it
sounds like a crime doesn't mean i can
be charged because i'm immune because of
the president and donald trump and blah
blah blah blah blah um
i'm trying to see so it says uh
scott mcfarlane says all right so day
four of the steve bannon trial opens
with the defense team arguing uh for a
motion for acquittal from the judge and
then if they argue to the judge that the
prosecution didn't make their case
uh defense it's really a one witness
case at best the testimony was equivocal
um
jury's not in the room judges taking
five minutes yeah trial is going to
resume
judge carol nichols reserves judgment on
bannon motion for acquittal
um
then he quotes uh uh
uh glenn saying the judge reserves a
ruling on the motion for a judgment of
acquittal until the end of the case
nothing has substance can be read in
into this in my opinion still waiting to
see if the defense can call any
witnesses present any evidence or if
bannon will testify no and then alert as
of one hour ago bannon defense attorney
will not present case to jury no
evidence no witnesses no bannon going
straight to closing arguments and jury
instructions it appears bannon will not
speak to the jury no witnesses on his
behalf no evidence of existence how long
ago was that was the closing arguments
because it looks like to me kyle cheney
has it here let me pull that up it looks
like it was almost 37 minutes ago okay
yeah this was just an hour ago yes so so
they're so they're in closing arguments
probably right now as is what's going on
right now um and that's a close trial to
watch even with the hearing tonight
because it depends on how quick this
jury can come back with a conviction if
they do but it is possible that we hear
folks that we hear a conviction the the
very first conviction in the select
hearings you got to remember
this will be the very first conviction
that happened with the select committee
if steve bannon is convicted today now
rather the jury does it that quickly
we'll have to see only time will tell
but this will be the very first
conviction
that comes out of the january 6th now
it's only because he's in contempt of
the committee right now this [ __ ]
bone it tried to tuck tail and say oh no
i wanna i wanna i wanna testify now this
only proves their desperation and that
they're scared of the consequences here
don't also it's like you have to look at
these people who came forward like uh
stuart you know stuart rhodes right and
steve bannon and these people saying hey
look i'll i'll come forward and i'll
testify in front of you and the american
people
unvetted
live
right and it's like okay not gonna not
gonna even try that because uh you will
very much try to throw this whole
[ __ ] committee under the bus to make
it not seem legitimate
and us letting you up here in front of
people unvetted not doing the deposition
beforehand actually getting the notes of
what you'll say
makes us look like a joke and and we're
not gonna do that we've done enough to
establish trust
and confidence with the the people that
are watching the citizens of the united
states you know because
there has been a turn in terms of people
that support trump and don't support
trump now thanks to these hearings so
they are making and even the members of
congress that were involved right we've
watched that net we watch that needle
move a lot too and whether they whether
they support it or had some involvement
and like oh [ __ ] i i see what's
happening here and they're trying to
avoid it
you know
whether
for good intention or just trying to get
themselves out of out of [ __ ]
um
they're
they're trying to get out of it so
they're gonna say oh yeah yeah this was
bad no no he should not have done this
right i mean you saw the people in
arizona that fox had that digital
segment on and they're like oh yeah you
know trump trump oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of weird when it's kind of
like weird it's very weird they're like
oh yeah you know trump should have known
he shouldn't have done this you know he
did what he did again they wouldn't be
specific about what he was doing that
was bad they're just like oh well trump
shouldn't have done what he did uh so
let's go for desantis right let's get a
new fuhrer let's get a new let's get a
new hitler let's do that that that one
didn't work that one didn't work let's
get a new one 1.0 was bad let's go two
points ready for upgrade actually goes
through the upgrade fascists um here is
uh adam kinzinger floating tonight i
want to show this video but i also want
to talk to you because i i don't
they supposedly yesterday or
yeah that tuesday and yesterday
announced that tuesday they received one
text message from the secret service so
i want to go through with you what you
think about how that's deleted and if
that will be part of the if any of that
will be part of this tonight but uh adam
kinzinger says he floats this video of
the deposition um and he says
what was he doing while the capital was
under siege and he here is of course the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
donald trump himself he says see for
yourself donald trump is a disgrace to
america like adam kingsinger is no more
[ __ ] at this point yeah i mean he's not
going to rerun
he knows he knows that
his is standing inside the fascist party
because he's not an outright fascist um
is diminished but let's
let's listen to what kaylee mcinerney
says here now again you see kaylee
mcenany is on the screen here in her
deposition but remember tonight her
deputy so the the secretary press
secretary underneath her her deputy
press secretary the number two in line
is gonna testify before the committee
and i bet they're gonna ask her why did
you decide to leave
right after the siege right after donald
trump
gave his statement seems really weird
you wouldn't just like stay the next two
weeks right that's all you had left
right but let's let's listen to what
these folks have to say about what
donald trump was doing and again it's
not hard to guess
i mean he's he's predictably
unpredictable folks let's listen was the
president in that private dining room
the whole time that the attack on the
capitol was going on
or did he ever go
again only to your knowledge to the oval
office to
the white house situation room anywhere
else
so that's my recollection he was always
in the dining room yeah what did they
say mr meadows are the president
and all during that brief encounter that
you were in the dining room what are you
i think
everybody was watching the tv
you know whether
he was watching tv in the dining room
when uh you talked to him on january 6th
uh
it's my understanding he was watching
television
what do you believe in
these discussions was that
was the violence happening visible on
the screen on the teleon television
yes right
now the best one is the assistant to the
to the president here yeah um let me see
if i can get her name on the screen i
think it's molly mike before she came up
i was like who is this person in street
clothes and i was like oh boy this is
not gonna be good no well she says she
says supposedly so she's standing
outside and everyone's going all he's
doing is watching [ __ ] tv he's doing
nothing that's what she's saying with
this with what
with the answer she gave her right
exactly and again you know this is just
another example of something that we
heard
even after like right after right or in
that day we were hearing these things
and afterward we were hearing how he was
just sipping on a diet coke and watching
the fox news and seeing how things were
happening and didn't do [ __ ]
right and then everyone's like no no he
wouldn't do that what was happening you
know it's like what happened during the
seven hour gap of time and 137
because they're hiding a lot of stuff
and speaking of hiding a lot of stuff
i want to go to these text messages
because i think most people understand
out there that even if you just like go
on your phone and you and you you
you delete a text message
and you and it'll ask you on most phones
like are you are you sure yeah like
don't don't delete something that you're
not sure of right and you click delete
right it's no longer visible on your
phone
but i'm not as tech savvy as you right
so how hard is it
to actually delete that text message
forever and ever and ever on that
hardware software wherever it lives on
the cloud how hard is it there are for
typical text messages there's like four
points we'll say four points that touch
each other right you've got my phone
my carrier's service their their server
so whatever you would have like like a t
and d or verizon verizon or whatever it
goes to their server
then it goes to yours right
let's show whoever i have right right
and then it goes to your phone right
you're hitting you're pinging cell
towers coming between but the data has
to be transferred through
to say like here are the contents of the
message right so i sent you a text that
say hey what's up that goes through boom
boom boom boom you say a lot worse [ __ ]
than that yeah i know
these messages are stored locally on
your phone for however long you keep
them right and you can even you can even
set it to auto like your phone can
automatically set for a certain period
of time yeah i think like iphones it's
like if you haven't uh had a
conversation for over 30 days or
something like that it'll automatically
remove it now probably depends on the
hardware but if you're if you're
deleting it off the hardware is it
really deleted off the hardware it can
be recovered on some of that hardware
it can be recovered to certain extent so
like if you're using a phone like okay
if it's an iphone it's uh
and you're using imessages that's
between imessage and imessage so apple
is very very very very much on the like
we're going to provide security and
privacy for you as a user this goes back
to the san fernando shooting when they
were trying to get the information off
those backgrounds right right and so
that's one another example you know like
because the government's like oh we need
to back door into all these carriers in
case something goes and something in
case something happens and we need to
retrieve data like like the secret
service would delete text messages and
they needed it
but you look at the at the shooter in
that case and they were like hey we need
this and apple's like
like uh sorry like this is
because they didn't because at the time
because there was a federal lawsuit over
that right
the the fbi the department of justice
sued
uh apple for that back door and apple's
like look we don't have it yeah
we don't have a back door like it's not
a thing that we have like our encryption
is to where we don't have one right and
and i remember the case because
some of the fodder back and forth was at
the time was that the fbi and the amount
of time it would take them to actually
go through the process of suing could
probably just find the back door which
they did yeah yeah which they did
so there's other ways to retrieve it
right like if you physically have the
phone and you're able to get access to
it if there's a backup of said phone and
you want to retrieve that backup which
are typically done through a cloud
service or on your computer locally
now
if you have a phone i'm not sure what
phones that the secret service uses for
their for their job it might be iphones
because that has become the
the kind of
uh
the example of privacy and security for
apple they're the ones that they go to i
remember when that shifted over from
blackberries to iphones for obama i
think it was the first one he started
using one
um
yeah i think he even talked about it on
jimmy jimmy fallon's show yeah jimmy was
asking him about his phone i believe i i
don't know if that was the exact
interview but he was like it's not
really a phone it's just it's like a
it's just got music on it right yeah
yeah so there was concern early on and
then it shifted i mean trump had two
iphones i believe so i wouldn't be
surprised if the secret service were all
seasoned iphones who knows i also don't
know what special security
uh um
software or or uh proprietary
um
software applications that the secret
service uses right um because obviously
these things right you're saying the
government the government may have a way
they might not be using imessage they
may be using a different they might have
something else so the other thing that's
important here is yeah so you delete a
message so let's say i'm on the phone
i'm like i'm going to delete this
messages like hey what's up right you
delete your messages hey what's up now
technically they're still on the phone
there's bits of data that can be
retrieved from there now and the
hardware of the phone right right so if
there's a if there's a text message not
an imessage but a text message that can
that can be retrieved now imessages is
is going to be more difficult right
unless you have access to the phone or
the backups then you probably will not
get access to those messages so what
about on the other side of it then like
on the receiving end yeah on the
receiving like you text me and then you
delete that text right and it's a text
message
right right you still have it on your
phone right right now when it comes to
pinging the cell towers and connecting
through the servers where the data is
stored there's only so much that is
actually stored so like if you look at
um
uh
different carriers they have different
protocols in place so like if you have a
text message
the contents of that text message for
like a verizon is stored i think up to
five days but t-mobile att sprint nextel
whoever they don't keep the contents
right is that why you think that the
department of justice because we
we there was a report the other day
about these text messages that the first
requests for these text messages were
way back
right after january 6th right do you
think that's why because they knew hey
that timing is important here because it
it could automatically be scrubbed you
know not not intentionally like someone
actually went in and physically deleted
something but it could automatically
that data could be lost um just because
of what what automation is in place to
delete that data right and i think i
think even virgin mobile um is up to 90
days so they're like the most amount of
everything but verizon has three to five
days
the the uh the just the details of the
message you know can can be up to 90
days you know for some of these places
that's just like the d like who sent it
when it was sent that kind of
information but the contents of like hey
donald trump is throwing a tantrum in
the uh in the car in the suv right now
that those contents wouldn't be there
right he's choking me he's choking me
so the other thing that's important to
keep in mind is that the only reason you
would send a message or an email or
something like because these are also
emails that too that i'm sure they're
looking into that have also been
mysteriously just
it's because you don't want to say
something over the radio channel because
everything what what whoa whoa what you
mean you mean like the little ear pieces
and stuff right they say
like oh hey whatever and i hear you here
right you're like all recorded like
those are all the cheat the cheetos in
the cheetos choking the other guy the
cheetos joke in the other game all of
that stuff is is recorded those are logs
of conversation because they need to
know and go back and say like what
happened during this event like so they
know the tick tock if something if
something bad were to happen they
actually have that evidence right so
they have that now they said oh we lost
all of the phone stuff like all of the
text messages for those two specific
days that you want we lost them during a
a
just like i lost them a proto like a
procedure of resetting right
uh except the fact is
this [ __ ] was scrubbed right come on i
mean do you really believe that the
coincidence that when they did some kind
of data reset that they just lost those
text messages these are the things that
are supposed to be backed up so they're
like we're supposed to back it up to
make sure that we have uh
right like an archive like an archive
exactly because then then you move into
where the data archives team uh is now
requesting this to be like you need to
provide in 30 days
you need to provide us
uh documentation as to
why why
and when and what the contents of those
messages were that you deleted
so here's the thing i see someone saying
that the phone carry has a text they
don't have the text right they they have
the only information they have to the
extent is that they will be able to tell
you who sent the number that sent it
what time they sent it and then they can
tell you like geolocation kind of
information but they can't tell you the
contents that stuff is going to be gone
unless the phone was backed up
or you have the original phone with the
message that we were sending to each
other but other than that you'd have to
have the actual secret services physical
device but again these are things that
were supposed to be backed up they were
supposed to be archived they were
supposed to go through a clear procedure
to make sure that they have this
documented and what they did is oh we
went through a reset and some data on
the fifth and the sixth surprisingly
enough just went missing we don't know
what happened it just boom gone
so that's that is how it works between
different carriers they all have
different kind of rules that they follow
in terms of the length of time
but
i mean you only have five
days from verizon 90 days from virgin
mobile to get the you know get the
get certain amounts of it back but again
you know unless you have the phone or
you have the backups or access to the
backups and access to certain cloud
services that were connected
you're not gonna get so you really think
that these text messages could be gone
it is possible because i mean they say
once so what do you think the one what i
mean if you i don't know i i i guarantee
that one message the fact is they're
like oh we really found one it's
probably one that says like or the eagle
has landed or like the mogul is in it is
it's just it's just it's just benign
it's going to be something so simple
that is that a standard like the moguls
coming out of the white house you think
they saved just that one just to make
sure that they had one that they could
turn over yeah i mean like if i yeah i
guarantee that they're like okay well
here's one message so just you know that
we were talking right yeah here we got
one we found one we lost the rest of
them but it's it shows that we were
willing to
that's enough right and again
you know the re the fact that these are
all gone and that they were just
mysterio mysteriously deleted on a reset
and you know it's just one of the things
where it's like oh yeah well you know
it's like my dog ate my homework no that
[ __ ] didn't happen you
didn't do it or you
[ __ ] deleted it here's a couple
different scenarios because i
i want to have fun with this here with
this what this text message could be so
i i mean obviously it could be new phone
who dis you know that's a that's
probably a popular answer but
i i want it i would like for it to be
something like he needs his diaper
changed again or uh catch up against the
wall something
right you know
i i will i will point this out because i
saw anonymous tweeted about this
yesterday and they said uh you know
typically store of up to 90 days you
know between places
so so the group that it can actually if
there's someone out there that isn't the
government that could retrieve this data
it's probably they were like
which is also true the thing that i do
want to mention is that they did call
out the nsa and they're like if there is
anyone out there who could
go and
violate people's privacy
it would be the nsa they probably have a
recording of them already you should go
talk to them because they
might they might be the only place that
would be able to retrieve said messages
because they are constantly monitoring
what we say right because we have to
believe listen to this right now because
we have to believe that the nsa um is
collecting and copying all data
everywhere that they possibly can right
and they're archiving it it's not now
i mean it sounds pretty nefarious
but they are they are probably trying to
take every single piece of data that
they possibly can gather and archiving
it in the moment that they possibly can
as fast as they can like that's their
goal is to archive this stuff right now
they're just they're just scraping
through right you're just collecting
everything and you know they're
organizing how they want and
categorizing but yeah nsa might be the
only people where it's actually who
could do that which do you i don't
believe that we would ever see that from
the nsa i don't believe that unless
i don't know because here's the thing
like it's hard for they're just a
committee right they're not convicting
anyone they're not charging anyone right
just making a recommendation so it would
i if it got to a point where the doj was
like hey these messages are pertinent to
the case and we need to see what they
said it's possible they could work with
the nsa to get that stuff right and we
would never hear about it right until
after the fact
but
that would be the only thing because
right now that would be tough discovery
though even for a federal court and a
federal judge
because you don't know if you don't know
if nsa has it so i think i i mean
realistically that's what i want i'd
want the nsa to hang out that's
something
i don't i don't know that i don't know
that that way i think that would be a
really a tough shot so
my guess is that we only see this one
text message whatever the hell or
whatever the hell is it rather it's
about the ketchup diapers i guarantee
they're going to call them out tonight
they will say we will show it i think
they i think i think they'll show the
text
possibly show the text depending what it
is i mean especially if it's suddenly
like super trivial they're like oh we
got this one done next young
[ __ ] two days after after the
fact we requested these text messages
you know but again this isn't the first
request for these now it is one of the
first requests from the select committee
right but the department of justice
wanted these archived
just days after january 6th happened and
one of the reasons why the department of
justice wanted this information a
catalog the days after for one reason is
because it could be automated you know
the automation could delete this
information but the other reason why is
because there were i mean
they had just mountains and mountains of
data there were social media videos
there was ping points there was all this
data that they had to like you said
scrape they had to make sure they gather
up as fast as possible so that they
could use for the prosecutions to find
out what the [ __ ] happened for these
thou a thousand people you know making
their way to the capitol and some of
them going in and and destroying the
capital smearing their [ __ ] on the wall
and some of them committing violence
some of them killing police officers
it's like they had to make sure they
gathered up all that evidence that they
possibly could gather and and it's the
secret service was part of it and i
believe that we're gonna see tonight
because i think the other side of the
187 minutes of what trump wasn't doing
is actually
what mike pence was doing right that's
part of that 187 minutes we haven't
really heard that detail yet we saw
pictures
and and very small snippets of mark
short his chief of staff when they were
in the parking garage and you you saw
this
this vision or this image
of
pen standing at a loading dock is what
it appeared to be
and he's holding a a pen a piece of
paper and a phone and it almost presents
the select committee's almost presenting
that mike pence is standing there
holding the govern government together
with a phone
a pen and a little notepad right now the
word is is that mike pence was trying to
see
if he had the authority
with other politicians the speaker of
the house and the majority leader
are the minority leader and and maybe
even the majority leader mitch mcconnell
yeah if they had the power in the
government
to actually call in the dc national
guard because
by all standards the president is the
one who has control over them right but
the vice president with the control of
other people circumvent these people
right right now there's also talk
there's also talk from tonight's hearing
that we are going to get to see
the um
um the other versions right of the video
that he recorded the bloopers right yeah
the the version that the video that he
put out on twitter where he's like oh we
love you we love what you did great job
and you just failed so go on home you
know and and we love you though
i love traders i love tr i love people
who try to make me dictator and and tear
down our democracy
but i believe we're supposed to possibly
see clips or if not the entire entirety
of those outtakes as it were
and it feels like
the reporting is saying
that his staff was telling him in that
moment because they it they worked
really hard to get him to do the video
that i was supposed and i think they
were actually telling him look if you
don't do this they're gonna 25 you
yeah you're not going to be the
president here in about an hour if you
don't have your red button you won't get
your right
you will sit you will sit being 25th for
the next you know and i think when they
invoke the 25th through there i think
it's he has 10 days or something there's
a process that happens right i mean you
get evicted
out you're done you know well well no
you just you actu actually the president
united states when he gets 25th they sit
in limbo um if you go read if you go
read the process in the protocol they
actually have they actually have a
certain way that they can protest it um
the president can actually protest it
there's an official way to protest i
mean there's a protocol with the 25th
amendment and but but there's a certain
time period but basically what it would
do is handicap him to where
mike pence would at least run the
government for about a week
right right and i think that's the thing
that donald trump didn't want
is because he knew bad [ __ ] could happen
to him yeah yeah if my heavens i have
the video if we want to give it for
content yeah yeah do you have the link
uh yeah let's give me give me the link
and i'll um
uh if you've got a link there i'll play
the because this is the one that was
actually posted
on social media this is here i'll just
i'll just upload it oh okay yeah yeah
yeah oh oh you you you i hope the video
i haven't because here's the thing i'm
i'm trying to i'm trying to get this day
seven i gotta record yeah yeah i let
people know that that's probably why you
were a little behind yeah yeah yeah
you're working on a website i'm working
on it but this is one video i think i'm
gonna
show to at least tease what happens in
an okay so let's let's play the video
here it's it's one minute so bear with
us it's disgusting it's gross but let's
play it so people know this is the video
that actually played on social media and
tonight we may see the outtakes or the
other versions of this video
i know your pain
i know you're hurt
we had an election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election and everyone knows it
especially the other side
but you have to go home now
we have to have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt it's a very tough period of
time there's never been a time like this
where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us from me from
you from our country
this was a fraudulent election
but we can't play into the hands of
these people
we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace
oh my god one piece
it's been a while since i watched the
full the
full one minute or one minute in one
second i just want to know like in the
bloopers if they're like if they've got
one if they've got cue cards right i
want to know if someone's got cue cards
and then or if they've got a
teleprompter or like just remember to
say go home right right tell
you know the other the other outtake
that might be hilarious is he's like uh
can you take the orange out the orange
it's real orangey
we we watch from the uh alex holder
documentary uh from discovery plus the
one of the outtakes he he he he noticed
he was orange and he didn't know why he
didn't know why that happened
why does that happen why does the orange
thing happen he can't figure out why he
looks orange oh my god but you know it's
been a while since i've watched that
full video but but looking back on it
that video is horrible absolutely
[ __ ] horrible
i mean it's horrible evidence just to
play this out in public now knowing what
we know from the from the previous seven
hearings yep that this [ __ ] knew
it wasn't stolen and he pressured all
these [ __ ] agencies and all these
state legislators he tried to have fake
electors he tried to he tried to get the
oath keepers and the proud boys
to commit assault on our democracy
physical violence and assault on our
democracy i mean be there january 6 it's
gonna be wild and this was the best one
this was the best version
this was it well you also have to
remember like he sent out a tweet that
said go home and then he made this video
and this video really just sells how
much
[ __ ] he gives which is not at all he's
only doing this because they told him to
do it well again i think that's the
other thing we're gonna find out tonight
is
were they going to 25th him if he did
not do this right right now now remind
me because twitter
twitter took this video down right or
they marked it
because it was soon after that is when
they actually took his account away they
marked it they you know because all of
his tweets and all the other tweets too
that were saying like the election was
rigged and done it like right starting
in you know november and december these
these tweets were getting flagged to say
this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] would you need to see a
president say like this [ __ ] and then
twitter be like no you're [ __ ] lying
liar this is [ __ ] it's not true
so i think it was they had flagged it
right after because i mean like remember
in the last hearing
we heard an anonymous twitter employee
talk about
the
the violence that was that was being
discussed online right and they even
went forward and was like hey
i'm feeling
this is going to go down losing sleep i
have anxiety over this if we don't do
something something's going to go wrong
and then it was like nah well you know
yeah you know do what we can
and this is just another example where
you know i mean they didn't take it down
i don't believe they took it down but
they they flagged it and then um
eventually his account got taken and
suspended so
well but this this video does not exist
on his account because his account
doesn't exist anymore right um and nor
would he probably put this video up and
be proud of it and the only reason why
is because
he he said he said go home stop stop
right right well then this video is
admitting some aspect of defeat right
right he's telling them
look we didn't pull this thing off like
we thought we would
so just go home you know this is one of
the closest things to concession that he
actually released exactly one of them
again you know it's the closest thing
that we'll get to it it's the only thing
that him admitting to it in the sense of
like
look we tried this [ __ ] crazy plan
guys but
like it's almost like it's almost like
he's like guys look we really gave it
our our real like a 100 effort here i
mean some [ __ ] died
like people got shot they you know fall
off they fell off the wall instead of
using the stairs like you're all some
dumb [ __ ] but
we gave it our we gave it a good try you
know ready for effort we didn't pull it
off we tried to kill the vice president
we didn't get there but we tried you
know i i got a great idea for for for a
video if they do give us this footage
tonight gabe here's here's my thoughts
because we love the whistle video here
is here is steve bannon um having the
whistle i'll i'll on the other side i'll
give you um my idea of if we get these
outtakes tonight of what what what video
could could happen here okay but let's
watch let's watch steve bannon get the
whistle treatment the show trial
the moscow show of the 1930s why is he
not here in person does he really have
covet is anybody [ __ ]
of course everyone is laughing here
because it's hilarious everyone's down
here one one guy back there has a getter
shirt on like he's like getting
exclusive content for the ghetto app and
he's like hold on hold on miller i'm
going to get you i'm going to give you
the video footage that you need you know
like that like and then this is the guy
is it the same person with the whistle
is it the same guy from the line or is
this just the whistle treatment
i don't know if i saw the guy from the
last one but this guy man he is like
[ __ ]
do you think he has a man he's got a
mask on he's like i'm not spreading this
or whatever
but
he's like really like
[ __ ] blowing like right
he is not seven
this is hard you know let's keep going
it's completely
absurd and of course bannon he's even
laughing he even thinks he's like oh my
god this guy's committed like a
[ __ ] here with this whistle he's
laughing so here's my idea all right so
it turns out i'm seeing some people here
that are saying that it is the same guy
it is the same guy that was at the gats
uh m marger taylor green hopefully green
now yeah yeah conference so that's what
people are saying uh i haven't confirmed
i'd like to get that guy's name let's
get him on the show let's get the
whistleblower on the show so here's my
idea here's my idea i think i know what
you're going to say here's my idea if we
get these outtakes we should we should
we should lift these outtakes and then
we should have the whistleblower right
well because you know
we we had to make someone had to make
sure that he stopped these outtakes
right he stopped doing these outtakes so
that he would get it correctly he would
do the sedition correctly if you're
gonna do sedition and you're gonna do a
video about sedition you might as well
do it correctly so maybe the
whistleblower was showed up at the white
house while they were trying to do this
this whole sedition video and why
you know i love i love my
insurrectionist video maybe the
whistleblower was the one who stopped
the outtakes and like nope not good
enough and then they redid it i'm just
saying all right let's start it again
and action and then he starts blowing
the way as soon as something stupid
comes out just starts blowing the
missile it starts blowing away exactly i
don't know i'm just saying maybe that
maybe there's a video i don't know who
knew who knew that like uh probably 25
cent piece of plastic was so effective
to take down a fascist right
you know you know woody guthrie
woody guthrie used to carry a guitar
that said this machine kills fastest and
this the whistle should say this whistle
because it seems two for two man because
at that point he was like
okay and then he walked away right and
then margaret taylor green and matt
gates especially yeah they ran away they
were terrified of that wisdom not back
down right that's also the same video
where they're like wait wait they said
that they said that in front of the
microphone while he was blowing the
whistle and then ran away there were
like three different renditions of that
video i made which is like i made it
always sunny the gang uh
you know will not back down or will back
down i made one where it was um
uh there were a couple s one was benny
hill right and then another one was
another song which i'm blanking out at
the time at the moment but
uh that was the same video where there
was the reporter that was like matt
gates is a pedophile he is a pedophile
oh yeah yeah yeah pedophile that she
kept kept going over again as they as
they ran into the street to get in their
cars
so
yelling and whistling is an effective
tool to
was it last week we watched the video of
rudy giuliani being called a [ __ ]
fascist i mean they were after him and
he was he was still on the campaign
trail with with his um
with his son's
test his test yeah well yeah their trump
style truck as if these [ __ ] idiots
ever have
desired to have a truck like that until
until the trumpers love to have these
trucks this is [ __ ] ridiculous so
again i want to tell everyone tonight
it's very important to join us
um now again the gavel goes down at
eight
eastern
but our coverage at the minus touch
network
starts at seven
seven o'clock
eastern is when we will bring the panel
in we will talk about the coverage then
we will go to the coverage at that point
and we will
go through the entire hearing during the
break which they more than likely have a
10 or 15 minute break
we will also have commentary in between
and commentary directly after the
coverage of the hearing and we will play
the entire hearing in its entirety uh
live for you to watch and with the
commentary uh on the midas touch network
so go over right now
or after the show
and and actually subscribe to the minus
touch networks youtube channel but also
set your reminder
for that video that day eight video at
the very very top at the very top
speaking of mind as touch did you see
they they made the news this morning
with their video
uh this i did not know they made the
news i know last night they had a
million views on the video they were
they were on morning joe this morning
they played this video on morning gym
yeah this is a new video um
it's out
it's called the wizard of wise
and obviously it's going after dr oz
which
i i'm surprised i'm surprised uh
this didn't come out sooner with the uh
with the eyes and the wizard and you
know the the play on the words here so
this is a fantastic video here we're
gonna play and now it has 2.2 million
views just here on twitter
baby so let's let's retweet this
and let's play the the wizard of lies
here this is
fantastic we've watched fetterman run
rough shot over dr oz yeah in
pennsylvania but this one this one
really lays into him let's watch
[Music]
we like you to keep your promise to us
if you please
[Music]
and now i've got the number one miracle
in a bottle to burn your fat
it is the new miracle berries lightning
in a bottle the miracle of the year it's
raspberry cheetos c
buckthorn alpha cyclodextrin green
coffee bean extract yeah cone syrup red
palm oil garcinia cambogia it's a
miracle flower a miracle pill brand new
miracle
do you believe that there's a miracle
pill out there
there's not a pill that's going to help
you long term lose weight live your best
life without diet and exercise
you ought to be ashamed of yourself
you may think magic is make-believe but
this little being
has scientists saying they found the
magic weight loss cure for every body
type
a recent study found the main ingredient
in those magic beans not only failed to
help lab mice it gave them the early
symptoms of diabetes
i'll fight to secure the border so we
don't have to fly illegal immigrants at
the airports like this in the middle of
the night he actually had to pay the
largest fine in american history for
employing undocumented workers 95
million dollars i can't even believe
this figure
i'm a resident of montgomery county i
voted twice so i feel
big time pennsylvania
for years he's lived in new jersey
social media still frequently shows him
at his north jersey mansion so he is
running for office in a state he doesn't
seem to want to live in you
he's completely changed his positions on
just about every issue at this point
bill cosby is a more credible tv doctor
i know you know how much power you have
you are very powerful if you are really
great and powerful you keep your
promises physicians say dr oz is a quack
and a charlotte the only thing that
people like dr oz care about is
themselves you're a very bad man
pay no attention to that man behind the
curtain
wizard
of lies boom a great creation of midas
touch
the super pac minus touch
that was good
that's good i got i got i got a hand
another another nail in the coffin
well i'll tell you what uh that brett my
zealous and his editing
top [ __ ] notch it ain't no wonder
he's a talented kid he is yeah you know
did you did you know he's he has two
emmys
brett yes red my jealous has two emmys
it ain't no wonder he can crank out
these fantastic videos
i hope he never stops this is it's
fantastic the little bits and pieces
that he put together for this uh yeah
this wizard of lines and of course uh
ben and jordy i don't wanna i don't
wanna and you know not give credit there
they're good too they got great ideas
yeah yeah great at marketing great at
ideas great at the overall
um you know we know we know these my
zealous brothers we've gotten to know
them well through these hearings
producing the hearings for the minus
touch network and uh but um this this
editing here with the with the words and
the music and the boy it just uh it
really it really shines through here no
wonder no wonder um morning joe wanted
to uh feature it on this on on the thing
i i want to say um with the dr oz
so
it feels like
i also wonder is oprah ever going to
apologize for introducing us to people
like dr oz and dr phil
well she should she should i she should
making these people extremely wealthy
and having uh like claire mccaskill said
the former senator from missouri
extremely powerful
i think i think it was heidi uh was it
heidi kud that was on her pipe she was
talking about this
the healthcare kind of the health pill
this this this [ __ ] this natural
herbal thing was it her that was on our
podcast uh months ago talking about how
that they use that as a right wing thing
because because that's kind of how it
seeped into joe rogan's universe right
he's kind of this naturalist he likes to
look for alternatives
right yeah they're like oh i don't want
to take the vaccine i want to find
something that's natural and what is
natural well you could take this pill
that can give you diabetes it's a bean
it's a great magic jack's magic bean
what in the [ __ ]
did you even know that he was selling
magic beans
i knew i remember uh well after i saw
this video i was like oh that's right he
did go forward and be like
but i do i remember when he was like oh
you could do this weight loss secret
like this is what you got to do
and um he was selling magic beans what
the [ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] what you know this is
alex jones type [ __ ] too yeah that this
is what this is how alex jones that
infowars makes a [ __ ] ton of money is
they develop their own little herbal
supplements and they act like it's gonna
cure you know the chemtrails or whatever
the [ __ ] right you know not turn you
into a lizard person or some [ __ ] and
you're supposed to take this [ __ ] the
other thing too is that these things are
not regulated by the fda yeah well most
of them are probably
placebos don't you think like right
because these are cheap [ __ ]
yeah yeah you can look at the
ingredients and be like there's only
like five percent of this and i think it
was even john oliver that did a segment
i don't know if it was related to this
one or if it was just the pharmaceutical
or not pharmaceutical but the herbal
market itself i think he dove into this
years ago and discussed how these things
are not what they they're not actually
what they say they are they're the
contents of them are like a fraction or
a small percentage of what they claim to
have in there the rest just like
particle bits that are just fluff you
know right
well and and i think i think the the
point here of of the video
is to make sure people know who dr oz is
and and fetterman
in pennsylvania has done a fantastic job
just a fantastic job of exposing that
this guy is a he's a fraud he's a phony
he's a quack it's no wonder it's no
wonder trump endorsed him
he's he's a
he's a fraud of course trump would be in
his corner here but i think the most
important thing
is that people realize that these races
matter
this really does matter when you're
selecting someone to be a united states
senator
where their main key to their content
and their and what how they got rich was
to sell people
magic
beans it's a get rich quick scheme they
don't care about the people they care
about the money i mean it's very true of
the republican party it's like i don't
care what happens as long as i get mine
and the people that are going to be
impacted by this negatively
are the you know they don't care about
them right you look at the people to
help with them right
oh you guys will die for me awesome i'll
paint music i'll pay for your you know
and some of the people he actually has
paid for uh which is a you know a bit of
an interesting thing that i think is
being pursued legally against trump for
uh covering certain legal costs for
certain people
um that the january 6 committee is isn't
interested in but
you know trump will promise all these
things for these people it's just like
these pills i mean like trump is he's a
snake oil salesman just like oz just
like anyone else of these these
republicans who promise these grandiose
things and these you little little bit
of effort
and a ton of of benefit that you get and
what you end up finding is that
neither of those things are true it's
not a little bit of effort it's a [ __ ]
ton of effort
and you get very little benefit and a
lot of the cost
is the actual
money
um i have a a clip here i don't mean to
interact no no this is um
um speaking of frauds
and this is louis gomer talking about
diamond and silk on the house floor
apparently and now now now louis gomer
tried to run in texas um heat loss so
he's not he's not going to be a member
of congress anymore which is really
disappointing that's so sad
that he's not going to be
oh man that's really oh
if i had this one
yeah
um so gohmert here is on the floor
talking about diamond and silk
and well
i don't know let's just listen to the
stupidity it's only 32 seconds of the
dumbest [ __ ] you've ever gonna regret
the 32 seconds of that well it's i don't
know exactly let's listen to 32 seconds
of the dumbest [ __ ] maybe this is a new
segment yeah i was just thinking this
could be the dumbest [ __ ] you can go
right the dumbest [ __ ] you've ever heard
32 seconds let's listen
it's time to get rid of their immunity
from liability for even fraud you can't
even sue them for fraud i'm like diamond
and silk they were telling me how they
had
they had paid in order to have their
name come up more often and now is he
drunk i don't mean to cut it off short
here i mean
i don't know i don't know if he who's
the [ __ ] is he talking to i think he
just needs to take the dentures out he's
like
okay so you know like that's what it
sounds like there's a little bit of
slurring maybe maybe that's how he
normally talks i don't know here's the
thing he says a lot of dumb [ __ ] he
talks about the moon
and [ __ ] yeah yeah right moving
moving moving the moon so that way the
the tides will change and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
okay let's
i think he's talking about social media
here is what he's talking about
and he invokes diamond and silk as if
everyone
on the floor of the house would know who
diamond and silver are
like the only reason why we know is
because we follow these [ __ ]
right-wing hacks let's listen not only
did it not come up more often than an
algorithm was used to send it to the
bottom
that's call fraud
what so he's saying if you post
something and twitter's like well this
is really irrelevant and they and the
algorithm sends it to the bottom that's
fraud what the [ __ ] is he talking about
is that what he's saying
again 32 more 32 seconds in the dumbest
[ __ ] you ever heard let's finish the
rest of the 30 i mean it's really been
really dumb so far it surely surely gave
it can't get dumber
they took money from them under
fraudulent circumstances they can't even
sue over that
so i'm for getting rid of that immunity
[Laughter]
social media do social media companies
have immunity uh
what is he talking about i have no
[ __ ] i mean
he i mean he's probably referring to the
immunity that is like
you know if things get well there's the
immunity of of companies you know social
media companies that's like oh [ __ ]
happens on here we're not right like
let's say me because i have some really
hot takes let's say i have a really hot
take and the hot take causes you know
some kind of chaos or something right
then then they can't be held liable
because i post it on their public forum
right right exactly that's the immunity
that he's that he's speaking of here but
it has nothing to do with them posting
and the algorithm
taking the [ __ ] post because it's
garbage
and it's irrelevant and the algorithm is
like and throw that in the trash that
ain't worth [ __ ] yeah
i mean what the [ __ ] is he talking about
and besides diamond and silk are always
trending on twitter anyways because
they're a bunch of dumb [ __ ] so if they
had any kind of clue they would realize
all i got to do is be dumb as [ __ ] just
be dumb as [ __ ] and say some of the
dumbest [ __ ] you can possibly say and
you'll end up on twitter like you you're
you'll end up there don't worry you'll
you'll you'll get to the top you will
get to the top i guarantee it it just
might not be for the reason you want
well we need some new music we have
bonehead of the week but um we need the
dumbest [ __ ] you've ever heard
this week's edition of the dumb [ __ ]
you've ever heard
we're workshopping it right here yeah
right here at live so speaking of that
because bonehead um is tomorrow all
right
there will be people i mean trump would
he's you know i don't know if to give
him dissonable mention
right we're not sure in the we're really
not sure yet because he's definitely
going to be somewhere in
the in the right i mean like there's no
way is dedicated to him right
so you know we might we'll probably see
someone else that goes through the tick
tock of what happened during the 187
minutes that reveals himself to be
another contestant on
bone head of the week
but um
well and and i think it could happen
during the year one two who knows so so
make sure to go follow at tony michael's
pod the podcast twitter account it'll be
over there also don't forget
do not forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel here the tony michaels
podcast youtube channel
that bonehead of the week poll
appears on youtube and twitter so you
can vote either place or if you want to
commit election fraud you can vote in
both places i guess yes yeah
we're not we're not quite as secure as
uh wisconsin's election now that they
got rid of their secure ballot boxes but
here's what here's what i'll tell you is
that tonight with this bonnet poll it's
possible that this thing even gets
released during the hearings because it
could become very clear to gabe exactly
who the three are yeah and boom that
poll gets released so so make sure to
not just watch the hearings
keep an eye on that on that bonehead of
the week poll because you know if you're
a new listener out there we go through
the bonehead of the week every single
friday in the second hour
the second hour every single friday you
vote for bone end of the week you decide
we break it down on friday in the second
hour the tony michaels podcast as we
broadcast every single day every single
day every day two hours
monday through friday two hours noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific and
twitter twitch we give you a recap on
saturday that's right the trust of which
will most likely be the hearing yeah i
think i think we'll probably break the
hearing up um and put it on the best of
that's been some of our best coverage uh
so far each week so we put a lot of that
in the best of so that's probably and
it'll probably just be the commentary it
won't be the hearing itself yeah i'll
probably pull the commentary from the
midas touch network panel and we'll put
it up on the the podcast directories so
you can download that or watch that on
saturday and then sunday like gabe was
saying bonehead of the week in and of
itself if you miss it on friday you can
catch it on sunday you can download the
tony michaels podcast seven days a week
gabe seven
days a week we are on the air yelling
and screaming
making sure everyone knows what is at
stake in our democracy
um
looks like
there's um um someone that tweeted looks
like there's a
bus that was turned over
um looks like river river parkway and
the bronx i'm not sure what what
happened it looks like um there's some
breaking news from there
um
i'm not sure it looks like some people
are injured there i hope everyone is
okay but a bus flipped over i'm not sure
if it was involved in an accident or if
it looks like it was going around the
corner um there i'm not gonna play the
video because
who knows who could not know who's on
that bus or not but uh stay stay with
that it looks like
i will retweet it but i don't want to
play it live here on the air um but if
you if you uh go look it's hutchinson
river parkway is the
is where it was at on the bronx so
breaking news there um looks like a
yellow bus was overturned looks like a
school bus not really sure looks like uh
some adults
are injured so uh be watching that story
develop on twitter and on the airwaves
as we go along here um anything else you
think that we're gonna hear from this
hearing that we've missed today because
i think it's just gonna be packed full
of a bunch of [ __ ] that we already know
that we're already assuming about the
former guy i think you know i think like
i was saying yesterday i think it's
going to be a lot of they have a theme
they have a of what they do right they
set up what we've all heard whispers of
rumors right there might have been some
person who came forward and said this in
the past or it was written about but
wasn't verified i think what we're going
to hear again is what we've seen so far
they're building on top of what we've
already learned right and they're going
to confirm
that you know you got kindergarten who's
releasing video beforehand to be like yo
make sure to watch out because this is
just a a teaser right of what's
happening right he even went on talk
shows on sunday and he's supposed to be
the one that goes through the tic tac
right right exactly so you know benny
thompson is out today or he's going to
be in remotely because he has covid but
kendrick went through sunday and was
like hey i can't tell you exactly what
we're going to talk about but like
specifics right now but what i can tell
you is this right and then an article
came out yesterday which was saying oh
they're going to go through the bloopers
right the outtakes the ones that they
didn't go through with and then we're
going to show like i don't know so i'm
curious like who who filmed that right
like who was the person behind the
camera was this with a phone someone had
a camera and they're like oh yeah this
is you know archived now
i would love to know who did that
but also you know even the sample clip
that he shared today which was everyone
confirming what we already knew he just
sat around and watched this [ __ ] on tv
and waited for to see how it would play
out and then made a video to be like
okay go home go home and i think that's
the other thing we're going to see is
those outtakes so i'm looking forward to
the outtakes i'm uh to see exactly what
they say and and what kind of
more seditious thing that they were that
he was thinking than what is in the r
and the one that was already citing more
violence so go subscribe to the midas
touch network youtube channel do not
forget to set your reminder for tonight
tonight
7 eastern 7 p.m eastern our coverage
will start on the midas touch network
please go over to the minus touch
network youtube channel
and again
go vote for bonehead of the week tonight
yeah because tomorrow is friday and
we're going to go through bone in the
week and i'm sure we're going to these
bonuses these bonus are going to reveal
themselves tonight at the hearing so
don't miss it we will have full coverage
with commentary
until
tomorrow we will join you tomorrow at
the same time same place noon eastern 11
central nine pacific youtube twitter
twitch and the midas touch facebook page
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking